these are
um they're a collab with Dennis Hopper
it's a brand called Jacques Marie major
oh these are really scared to ask this
yeah who is Dennis Hopper
Esther it's like can we Loop us out
[Laughter]
but it's these are gonna be you're gonna
see how these like cause like kid
glasses like they'll look like I'm
wearing like a child's glasses I can
already see how they're too excuse me
let me see oh they look good on you can
we see too skinny they're cool but
they're there's like meat on the side
look but it's a color it's like um
how much should they cost
um 750 I think okay I like them I was
about to be like oh boy she's poor you
guys speaking of meat I really do not me
that's it I really get the ick when
people refer to being a human as living
in a meat suit do you guys hear that a
lot and I get it because it's like I'm
all about the spirituality but meat suit
we gotta do better than this okay I have
a good one that's okay okay that's a
good bad one my ex boyfriend was on acid
and this girl came up to him she's he
was sitting there she sat like straddled
him she was on a skirt and she said do
you want to get in my warm [__] blanket
and then she sat on his dick wait your
boyfriend my ex-boyfriend he wasn't my
boyfriend at the time oh I was gonna say
you just let it happen no no I mean
maybe that was on that much acid no
that's like one of his stories he told
me warm so I think of warm [__] blanket
all the time I think it's it's kind of
sweet like if that's better than [__]
receptacle have you done acid yet no
mushrooms yes oh why yes do everything
but Coke oh is that heroin okay and wait
so but what's the difference between
acid and mushrooms that's what I've been
trying to ask people lately well one's
made in a lab and one grows out of cow
[__] but like no but it's it's so silly
like I mean you can get the laughs on on
mushrooms acid to me is like so bright
it's so silly it's so like well Dr Drew
said too that LSD specifically is
amazing for end of life dread so when
people are either like diagnosed with
like what about during this yeah
about no I'm still here dread I imagine
it's probably really good for that just
dread in general because if it's good
enough for someone to like who's been
diagnosed with a terminal illness to
accept death in like a positive way I
imagine it can help us just accept all
the bad [__] like I feel like mushrooms
kind of I feel like all hallucinogens
kind of do that I think it's so weird
because there's like colors everything's
like neon and everything but
um for all of them I'm just trying to
think what the difference is I don't
know acid longer I think how long it's
you know you could be up for 16. yeah
it's like yeah I don't want to be quoted
on this I'm like these are just my
experiences it probably depends on how
much you take okay also follow where's
my gummy bear I want gummy bear on my
[__] armpit oh gummy bear deodorant
yes we have The Gummy Bear uh body wash
how else am I gonna get Esther to eat
out of my arms other than to make it
candy
thank you to our sponsor rocket money do
you know how much your subscriptions
cost most Americans think they spend
around 80 a month on subscriptions when
the actual total is closer to 200 if you
don't know exactly how much you're
spending every month you need rocket
money stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday Miami I am
coming to do stand up April 21st and
22nd get tickets at Esther onice.com and
as always I have a solo podcast you can
check it out wherever you listen to your
podcast it's Audio Only and it's super
weird
hi sluggies I'm having the best time on
the road on the welcome to Annie wood
tour you can see me in Seattle this
March 10th and 11th you can see me in
Tampa March 17th and 18th in Toronto
April 21st and 22nd Riley North Carolina
May 12th and 13th I'll be in Salt Lake
City in June I will also be in Calgary
in August all these shows are going to
sell out there's also so many more
tickets coming and other shows so please
go to annieleterman.com shows and then
come see me every Thursday see my little
baby Annie wood my favorite little thing
my solo podcast that's on YouTube
um comment subscribe like it all that
stuff can't wait to see you
um Annie I saw you at the comedy store
on Thursday night and I have a question
because you in the Green Room at the of
the main room
you were very chill you were very
relaxed you were very calm does it seem
like I was on something yeah no what was
what was that about I was so happy I was
hanging out with Damian Leon all night
who is the guy who made terrifier too
who's gonna cut me up in terrified three
it was just so fun I was just having so
much fun you were just relaxed I was
having fun but I do my little my cards
every day I forgot to do them so
please help me this seems like you're
gonna ask me to do this okay but it
didn't okay so these are my xiaomi
my breathwork Shaman made these they're
so cool he painted them they created all
of them and then so I I take three in
the morning but it doesn't have to be
three but you take we take I take them
and then I take it sounds like a
medication I put them well I'm not
here's the thing he said are you high I
said no no it's on life in cars come
here so I get to take three sure we'll
just take one okay for now let's see
I hope it's a lesbian one
it is not
it doesn't look good I don't mine is
like scary it's what hey it's like a man
hey it is
it's actually not bad but it is like I
mean I know that the devil but it's not
but it's a devil but it's not bad but
it's so funny no I'll help you it's dead
but it's just funny that it got that you
got death but it's not it's not bad but
it's so funny but why is it not bad and
your outfit's kind of like dark today
what the [__] I love it though you know
I'm happy with that shirt yes a Royal
Caribbean cruise Casino very excited
about how is it not badass who brings up
a good question
um so it's more about going to the
depths of Despair to oh okay flush
things out and then bring rebirth I'm on
that path yes uh I claim my unseen
powers for my highest good I embrace
transformation with faith
love that not like Christian okay good
no that I am transforming you're become
a Christian I commit becomes a Christian
I'll die that's the funniest thing no
I'm definitely currently like my big
focus is
I I my at my addiction is to comfort
and I'm just trying to be like yourself
[Laughter]
to feel comfort and like lately I'm just
like trying to like do things I would
normally do and even though it's like
scary I just want to get out of it's so
hacky but like get out of your comfort
zone it's like I've just never done it
but it's fun it's like
but we've seen you eat some well I guess
you never hit the bugs but you screamed
and ran out of the room while we were
eating them that's why I like doing
stuff like that because you get like a
high after you like get through
something that you don't want to do yeah
I'm kind of doing my goal is the
opposite because I think Annie and I
have been pushed out like forcefully
pushed out of comfort like a lot in our
life so now I'm trying to reclaim my own
comfort and to be to offer myself the
comfort that I need in the moment as
opposed to like kind of like you know
being so proud of like living in the
pain of it all right you know that's how
I feel about when I like
um when I go back to New York I'm like I
was so proud to live in New York and be
like suffering through
the life of like I mean I've never been
had money in New York and that's
probably a very different experience but
like being broke in New York and just
feeling like I was like getting it felt
like reps like getting through every day
and I don't want that to do that I don't
ever want to like suffer through not
that I think if I lived in New York now
it'd be like that but I don't want to
have that like my
all of my Joys and the fact that I like
got through something I want to be able
to enjoy the things is that what you're
saying yeah that's exactly what I'm
saying that's like a common thing and I
I feel like I see people talk about this
a lot like living in New York is about
hustle and like
grinding and yeah yeah it's like our
Jaws are [__] up okay we don't need to
grind anymore we've grown enough well I
pulled um I took
um Chronos Titan god of time and
limitation oh what does that mean for me
so pretty look at that I like the blue
zombies are talented
this is what breath work that is if you
access all of your talents
okay so that is so cute oh my God I love
my shop he's so cute okay wait so what
does it mean it says I release my
Offspring or projects into the world
they find their own successful course so
instead of holding close to things and
trying to control them just like setting
forth the intention of them and just
letting them
manifest and trusting oh I like that I
think I'm just kind of riffing what I
would think if I pulled that card
I wish
that's not what Cronus means all right
it says okay so also it says
um okay after a season of growth you may
experience a time of withering like uh
we saw you went there
but I'm saying you did with her the
weathering's done let go of that which
needs to die Redemption comes from
surrender to Spirit we am I the thing
that needs to die that she has to let go
of no but I am your miscarriage should
pop into mine
um I'm sorry okay so it says penetrating
quest for depth I like penetrating
transformation
erotic and sexual mysterious is that
crazy as you were saying that I mean
you're saying all this and like I just
put a suppository up my [__] for
probiotic to fix what happened to fix
yeasty it's not a yeast I want people to
think that we did film these each a week
apart and then she's been crusted up
[Music]
I want to get something every day a new
crust Crystal forms in that place no
it's improving so thank you I really
feel like
um this I pulled the right card for
today all right so if you're imbalanced
you're going to feel manipulative
obsessive okay hold on manipulation
and deceptive you're going to be an
extremist so if you're feeling any of
those things like obsessive or like you
feel like you're manipulated you need to
manipulate something drop that and lean
more into the the transformation
probably go [__] honestly you should
probably go [__] if you feel that way
thank you thank you so much homework
assignment is so much better than mine I
didn't read your more of yours it says
depression and hopelessness will soon
pass how did you [__] know [__]
because they probably this card probably
follows you on Tick Tock
sad girl
[Laughter]
all right so yours is a change of
Fortune depression hope those will soon
pass a hidden power of self emerges so
maybe that's getting out of your comfort
yeah unseen aspects of Life surface so
all these places you haven't been going
to because
you're feeling like I want to stay
comfortable are gonna you're gonna
realize you love it there that's like
when I went to Bingo and I started
crying I was like a new thing I like
um okay so it's a time for Spiritual
realization and Awakening which may
bring challenges but you're on the path
of intuition into life's mysteries
it may be baffling but will change your
views uphold spiritual focus and protect
yourself
all right so a balanced expression of
this
of Hades reflects someone who's hidden
depths are hard to exp that are hard to
express wait I balance Hades reflects
someone with hidden depths that are hard
to express distrust of superficial
Society she chases the Kardashians uh
seeks intensely and means seeks
intensity and meaning so I feel like the
person who's doing this for me should be
able to read
I got
someone that's staying in their comfort
zone read when they're
diagnosed dyslexic well I get very proud
of myself
okay so in Balance expression of this
may show despair depression and
meaninglessness
flirting with negative underworld
activity and Outlaw or criminal danger
that's so I am recently hey never mind
no she's recently like micro dosing it's
like only you would think you're a
criminal from taking like this much
mushroom no I'm not the criminal
whatever
are you micro dosing
um I have experimented with that yes I'm
to me Micro dosing though is almost like
it's so not a big deal it's like I'll
take it for energy like it keeps me
awake so I just take it to like have a
little pep in my step like if I'm
working or something so you gotta try
acid it's so good I wish I could get
this one acid I did there was this as my
friend in Santa Fe made me or why he
didn't make me but he made it for people
and then I it came to me the I guess he
did make it for me because it it
appeared into into me but it was like in
a dropper form and we would it was just
the craziest thing I I just it was just
I think acid I'm not ready because
because I like I'm really into the
storyline the brand branding of like
mushrooms and weed being like from the
earth yeah that's I'm like but it's
crazy what you see like I remember the
first time you know what else is from
the Earth
all the other bad stuff like arsenic
mine is
um cryos
so cryo says I accept my ability to lead
and act decisively
so leadership and personal
accountability it's time to take the
reins of your own life for your own
advancement and show others the way
involves effort responsibility
obligation to your mission or followers
I'm starting to call guys thank you so
much I join I'm in I'm in me too but why
does your your card know that you're
like on social media and that you have
followers I don't know I just I know
they say tick tock followers may I go
grab my coffee yes you may
actually I'm the leader yes you can go
okay so I'm the leaders henchman
so initiating okay so when it's good
it's initiating courage and daring
fearless and pioneering vital and
enthusiastic I do feel like I have those
qualities when it's imbalance it's
Reckless impatient and angry headstrong
and combative I've never seen that part
of myself so
I don't know thank you um have you guys
heard of the
um there's this cold and I think they
only had like
20 members is that still a cult sure
yeah
um it's the the lady who called herself
like
um said mother God
it's like the Love is All cult where she
would no no no they they I think she's
originally from Colorado and then they
ended up in like Hawaii the love is one
call yeah
um
she's dead now but she made everyone
take like large amounts of like silver
basically and so she started to turn
blue like bluish gray she eventually
like died of cancer Esther are you on
Silver I've heard of like people turning
blue and I that I just remember that
part right indigo children because I
always I always really I always pick
like the blue flavor of things so my
tongue turns blue like that's kind of
part of my culture but I was thinking
that she is Genesis right
but I was thinking like she her name
like I really did find it kind of cool
that she had people call her mother God
like that's kind of has a ring to it I'm
like yeah what would your what would
yours be and you can have time to think
about it I think we should really make
sure we come up with our good ones like
what are what would your cult leader
name be what would you make your people
call you
um
I'm not sure let me think on this okay
this is a serious question
that's so scary I have seen your Norman
Bates do it yeah
her other nicknames were mom and Mama G
Mama
said we were talking about
handmaids and I was thinking this
morning
I think that me and kalila would be good
handmaids but I can't can you discuss
Martha as you think okay we're talking
about a handmaid's tale handmade yeah I
want to know do you think first season
refresher so the handmaids the handmaids
are the girls that we make we have the
babies the marthas are the women who are
are not making the babies but they are
cooking in the kitchen
I am a hand no the handmade just lays
there and gets [__]
we have to have the baby yeah and then
you only get to hang out with it yeah
but I just want to know like I feel like
I could I I still went as far as a baby
it's gonna be the same size as her isn't
that crazy could you behave and be
handmade I want to know
no I would have been killed dad in that
Society yeah I should be biting dicks on
like the first night you know I had to
stop watching that show because I
watched the first season but I was in a
relationship with a guy who was such a
guy like it was like I couldn't he would
have been these [__] if we watch please
[__] think they're gonna get [__]
you know what I mean it was like way it
was the wrong guy to watch it I was like
so I but maybe I'll revisit it but I
have to watch it all over again because
I don't remember I think you're wrong
about me I think I'm a Martha yeah I'm
like a domesticated Asian mom yeah but
that's what I have to be the
Alternatives I think I'm a nothing I
think I'm literally so you can work in
the brothels no I think Annie would be a
handmade but she'd be one that's like
you know plotting I think we would plot
and have like a secret network if we
were all handmaids yeah okay wait again
I need more explanation because I I'll
have an answer I have an answer for you
okay so the handmaids lay there get
[__] obviously we can all do that yeah
I don't know about my hospital bed I
just got a trampoline like for exercise
and I'm like how do we turn this into me
having to do less during sex I literally
was like
hmm
do you guys know that the average person
has around 12 paid subscriptions
I do and it makes me feel sad for how
many I have well think about so much
more so many more like think about it if
you think you've only subscribed to a
handful of services you might want to
double check with rocket money you can
quickly identify and cancel all of your
unwanted subscriptions rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about like streaming
services that you bought that where you
just watch one show and then you
literally never use it again Army Hammer
free trials you you've never used and
Rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones that
you don't actually want and they're so
tricky like try it for 30 days and it's
like I'm not gonna remember no but I
always fall for it I fall for it every
single time and they make it so
difficult to cancel you know what the
worst ones are are the ones where they
get you for the year have you ever
bought a yearly like I've been time
somewhere like it'll just be easier to
do the year like completely forget it's
a total app that I stop using within
[__] three days days within three
days and then you know you don't see it
for a whole year and then it's like a
chunk out of your bank account stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com
I really want to get a sauna does anyone
hear like a sauna girl yeah but I I do
like saunas but I'm telling you it's
been activating a weird thing in my neck
recently the getting in the heat but if
I don't go in too long I think but um I
love them yeah you get those little
outdoor like drivers they're really cute
if I had your backyard I would have one
immediately I was thinking putting one
inside no no outside they have those
little Barrel ones the wood ones no you
can't even do fancy you can buy it on a
Wayfarer for like three grand it comes
with a 17 year old girl
it might it might because the girl named
Julie uh it comes with your own handmade
what about cold plunge I have yes you've
done it yes you have it's like it's like
a religious experience like you're in it
I did it with Lacey my trainer and and
we were like
I as I'm in a you like give this
surrender and she's like giving me box
breathing instructions you know what box
breathing is yes eight seconds in herbal
four maybe in four seconds hold four
seconds release four seconds hold four
seconds yeah yeah I think I was doing
eight with her butt
um so she was like leading that so I'm
like focusing on her and by like
minute 30 I think I did three minutes I
was three minutes is long it might have
only done a minute or I don't know I
can't remember at some point I said
I went like I would do Ayahuasca with
you I was like I would do anything with
you like I like I was like I give myself
to you that's what happens when I when I
do anal if you get me to agree we
actually see the connection if you do
get me to agree to have anal like you
own me you own me I am your business I
do feel like that's but there's
something internally like chemically
that changes inside me because I'm so
stiff I'm sorry do you give up the ass
easy not well okay so
I know you know you can get stuff out of
giving up the eyes they're like out of
other activities you're like if I give
you the ass I'm not gonna have to do
this I definitely was really into it in
high school for some reason I was very
sexually agreed what
this is how young you looked in high
school so crazy that you were the anal
that's insane Esther I definitely like
was very sexually explorative in my high
school days was it with women though it
was with everybody
and um but yes you think you were
letting guys like take every hole
because they were like maybe it'll make
me feel how I feel the woman no you say
guys like there's plural okay I had I
did it with one guy in high school and
now he locked his back door
back door and now his house is on
[__] lockdown
but um no I I am I dabble I'm into it
I'm very proud yeah
yeah it's a weird thing it's a
psychological thing I've only done anal
with like three boys in my life yeah
Each of which it's like you you own me
psychologically you own me because I'm
so afraid of it and
um I stiffen up there is a sense that
like I don't feel free because it hurts
me so like but if we get through it
together there's almost like a bonding
metaphoric moment afterwards yeah I am
mad at them though because I'm like
you're the thing hurting me and you're
the one that wanted to do this and then
also that it does hurt for like for a
few days it's not my ass already has
slippery problems things are already
going on with it it's like what are we
doing you know I woke up the only good
thing though is that it will shove the
Hemorrhoid back up for a sec I woke up
this morning and was like you know what
we're not we're we've been recording a
lot we're not going to talk about sex
today and then here we are anal's not
sex what did she talk
we were talking about cold plunges
she turned it into animal guy it's about
like you know domination you right you
belong to Lacey after I belong to I was
like I'm Yours she was like I will I
wasn't looking for a nanny I have a
tragic story about a girl who dances
Samba really well
um not only did she dance samba and
teach um she got butt [__] all of her
intestines started falling Annie um
they were swinging around on the ground
like a sausage link not that far off
actually
so this is a girl who was sort of just
like she bragged about how she only she
like loved anal love they know that but
we sort of noticed as a friend group
that every time we would go dancing like
there was always a stench of like
someone just like like a like a just a
thick fart cloud always around us and we
were like what is happening how can we
every time we go dancing and we were
like oh cause
her little heart out and they think her
just [__] would just like release Air
without I mean involuntary that I think
is better case scenario than she has a
rank stink butthole because that can
happen too you can have like a
intestinal issue I mean you know about
smile
I feel about intestinal issues but oh
I'm not saying as a nurse not like you
have a stinky right bottle
but I have I dated a guy who was such a
[__] [__] but I dated a guy who
I've told you guys before I dated I was
like I have a really good Keen sense of
smell which makes me like I'm literally
do you also own a gun because those two
things go together I mean I just was
like are you kidding me and it's after
of course you've banged twice you're
like oh no
he's like me twice he already whatever's
going on twice he's he's averaged and
what is the truth
when we when he broke up with me I
literally had to be like was it the
smell I'm like if you broke up with me
and you started telling people it's
because I have a stinky [__] okay he's
like you don't have a stinky [__]
that's not what it is I was like okay I
would much rather be a stinky
personality
stop this whole
smell
that like that that's not a thing no it
is a thing but here's the other thing
guys your dick smell like spicy chicken
butter chicken at a [__] Indian
restaurant okay you smell like [__] your
dicks are disgusting they're horrible
they're not any better than ours I don't
I think I don't know it is a thing we
have to see it like not in like a PC
kind of way let's accept it all there's
a reason why we have a sense of smell
there's a reason why we should be able
to detect infections pH is off those are
things that relate to health there's a
reason why [__] smells and that we're
you know deterred from the idea of it
smells or smells like certain things are
scientifically I don't think I told you
guys what do you know what I mean it's
like you want to accept it all but when
I first started dating Todd I bled on
his dick every time we [__] okay and it
turned out I had like a yeast infection
that was undetected but I thought I had
like no it is it is it was it didn't
burn sorry
um
no it didn't feel good but it wasn't
like it wasn't like a full-on thing so I
thought I had H pylori H pylori but H
pylori
ulcer oh wait that's different yeah I
thought I had to check for that so many
times helical back there yeah
it's just you had to take a poopoo no
they just do the the this is they just
squeeze a little harder oh my God no it
was a mouth issue have you ever gone to
the doctor and then been like just
squeeze harder for your poop to come out
no are you sure yeah if anyone I've ever
met it's got to be you but Esther why
don't you think smells are important why
don't I you just don't like the label of
stinky I just think there's like this
whole culture of like of guys I dated
my [__] yeah and it's like if if
there's like a serious issue which I do
have a guy friend who often will say
that he can tell if someone like what
they have because he's hooked up with so
many women I'm like you're gross we know
exactly who it is
but you're lucky to be there I'm just
why why is that a thing that men get to
make fun of us for oh you're saying we
get to make fun of everybody gets to
make fun of everybody for everything
that's the thing I also think that more
back it's just we just all have to eat
it out it's all like and also the thing
is sometimes your pussy's stinky
sometimes it's not stinky sometimes it
smells like [__] sometimes you gotta
[__] BV like it's like it's just it's
different but this guy it was very
telling that within the first couple
weeks of me dating him he was talking
[__] on other like he said um he's like
if you ever see like a hot actress
who's like in her late 40s and never
married he's like that's a stinky [__]
girl and I'm just like stinky [__] girl
but then he sent me into like a spiral
where I was like calling ex-boyfriends I
was like I'm not like a stinky [__]
girl right yeah this guy was like
mentally he's gonna die alone yeah but
also oh he'll die alone I just imagine
there's something else there too like
anytime I anytime I hear guys like that
who are very like kind of like snide or
like there's something else yeah there's
something else it's either mommy or you
wanted to bang your Daddy yeah it's a
daddy you want to bang Daddy for sure
but I also think yeah and I think it's
like
when the guys that are nitpicky and like
want you to be this like perfect
specific thing it's like yeah lose my
number yeah I just stop because it's
like [__] about those guys I'm like what
my thing with the smells Esther is that
like I I accept that I get the yeasty BC
some of my pH is off whatever but the
guy that I'm with is still gonna accept
me for all of my smells of course and if
he doesn't like what a person yeah no
your partner of course but if you're
like dating someone they're like that
it's just they're just showing you that
they suck I want to ask you guys a
question
this is really really important to me
and I have fought
I've had many many fights about this
topic for a long time but do you guys
think men have to consult their Partners
before shaving
yes
men have to consult well actually like
it's so boring because whenever I'm
asked that I'm like I don't know let's
do whatever really yeah no are we
talking about chest genitals facial hair
oh I think a gen a light conversation
you know a touch base like
I think that if I was gonna cut all my
hair off really short
I would want to run it by Dave I
wouldn't let them know that you're about
to leave them for
Tina
I wouldn't if he said don't like I
wouldn't let him decide for me not to
when your best friend got married were
you crying like Cameron Diaz I
definitely was weird at her wedding it
was like a little bit like like a door
had clothes it was yeah like an option
was over well I also refused to get
married before she got married which I
also think now looking back was weird
and then you were like daring her like I
dare you to discover Really Gonna Get
Married that's a long goodbye yeah a
long kiss goodnight I was correct it was
Gina Davis
um the
um but I I think I understand what
you're saying like sure just just honk
the horn that's all I need because if
you come home and one day in the morning
you're a bearded guy and then at night
you're somebody I've never seen before
like my my alarms light up and it's
stranger danger like who the [__] are
you like I started you do kind of have
to re like get into them that's what I'm
saying because it's like if babies have
such a visceral reaction to their dad's
shaving like they cry they're like who
the [__] is that like I have that same
exact thing that happens to me like I
don't know that face I'm not familiar
with it like you could have warned me
all of a sudden you're chinless like
there's so many things that go on like
and I'm not attracted to that face I'm
not familiar with it I relate to that
also in a different way which is that
whenever Dave goes out of town or one of
us is gone forever
like I like if he comes back
I'm I'm like no I I get weird and shy
and then he's like oh you have to warm
up to me like so we have this thing
where like I have to get to know him
again yes no I you have to I think even
in long distance relationships so funny
how long will he be gone for not long
it's very annoying of me are you like is
it you have to reacquaint though I get
that feeling that's funny what is it
like because you've started this new
life like alone in this house I think so
and I yeah I just I I was this guy in my
house I just feel that I'm like you have
to like
he's into warm up like I don't know I
relate yeah what is is that a problem
for me it's just a whole stranger danger
thing I pulled my like he pulled the
blanket off me and he like looked at my
[__] today and he said that I like
immediately got shy and like closed wait
did he spread it yeah he just was like
he was like let me see that thing and my
butthole just got like stop we have a
pot I have a nose see that's stranger
danger that's a no spread that's the
hottest part of anything like I talking
to everyone I have a question very
personal one
if you're on all fours like you don't
reach back and spread your well if it's
like mid that yeah that's fine
are we still doing all fours yes you can
[__] me from Mom laying down I'm not
listen I've been doing leg exercises
we're not continuing this okay
you can scratch me like stretch lab just
I'm saying a random spread is like [__]
no no I also
in my stomach any no
I haven't it's no I call it's called No
Taps like you can I just there's
something about tapping that's what she
needs she needs tapping that's going to
be the the your therapy that saves you
is tapping it might be your comfort zone
you have to get tapped you're right why
you have to be you have to be surprised
Brad
six times this week that's right wait
surprise bread spread
it's so funny it's so funny Todd will
just yeah and I'm like what my butthole
was like what is that no
oh that's a good reflexes but what means
is it was very relaxed and open that
means because it had to it had to recoil
um why the no Taps on the belly is it
like a it's one of those like it's like
a Nails on chalkboard thing it's like it
just makes me uncomfortable it's a
sensation thing yes exactly Oh I thought
in my head I was like it's uh like
eating this order thing no no it
literally that's the sensation of being
touched in the same area like oh like
more than once yeah freaks me out does
anyone else you should have gotten
occupational therapy like me [__]
they scrub scrub scrubbed it was the
worst it was the worst feeling I ever
had but I am so much better at touching
now being touched what if that was them
just like we wanna we're gearing you up
to get molested more you're making this
so difficult you keep saying no scrub
scrub
um my favorite thing that you I've seen
you say to Todd is when you're like Todd
I'm single now no I go Todd you're
single
you're single well you're single now
I've been saying really obnoxious like
things like pulling from like Nicki
Minaj lyrics
like I'll say things well no I'll say
things like because I'm a millionaire
this [__] is pricey in sex you say that
no just like you know in car rides like
but you go to jewels
I can't wait to move my niece out here
obviously not a millionaire but I'm just
I like saying it because it's like for
me it's like manifestation right it's
like it's like an affirmation like and I
say it out loud but guys you know they
they like it they think it's funny
because it's like it's a cocky stupid
thing to say fun to be cocky I'm also
team cocky I'm learning from you it's
good it's funny I'm like do you know how
pricey this [__] is good do you know
how many [__]
billionaires on Yachts could be [__]
in this room
not Leonardo it's under construction
though for him
if you could [__] Leonardo DiCaprio that
would be cool for us
um
no but if you could make it happen
it's not good sex it's like been written
about it's like he puts headphones on I
know and you know they're the Maxes wait
I want to know I want to know I haven't
heard this yeah he wears headphones and
then and he like zones out I think he
like Scrolls Online
says he Vapes and goes on his airpods on
hey there's nothing wrong with anyone
vaping while they're banging you I agree
actually or scrolling
I've had times where I'm like do you
mind if I text my friend real quick now
it's hard but wait a second so he's he's
not being present and he's just there
[__] him then and he's just there's a
deep rooted issue there if you can't be
present I mean that's what when I used
to be like when I would like hook up
with guys I wasn't like that into or
whatever I would always make it be
really rough and stuff because I had to
like disassociate so that's I guess what
he's doing right also you have to
imagine that like now all the things we
now know about child actors and what
they've been through like who the who
knows what that man has been am not
defending him at all like it's so weird
and whatever but
yeah it was if that's his pattern like
think about what the [__] could have
gone how sad would you have been if you
were a child actor and they didn't try I
was a child actor you weren't were you
were you a hand model though I I was in
a commercial and like I worked for a
year in fourth grade tell me everything
well I will say of this is for Walgreens
it was for Walgreens what was what was
your part like hey get me a
or is that what you did now in your
movie no
kids in the
life and we all said like different
wishes we had and my wish I wish for my
own shopping mall
and I also in my audition said I wished
for a flying monkey and then the uh one
of the sick little kids said I wish I
didn't have to take my insulin and it
was diabetes
I actually I'm taking a rosembic now
look how the tables have turned
it was a commercial floor juvenile for
kids with juvenile diabetes and
Walgreens that's [__] up yeah you kind
of remind me of the kilo diabetes girl
in our school she was a little
did anyone think there was anything
wrong with you when you were little no
I'm not that little there's so little
bring up the picture bring up that
little picture there's a lot of other
little you were so little that school
picture you Buzzy know which picture I'm
talking about when you were like the
gang leader of this guy two feet smaller
than everyone else
and we have bananas today I can't
I'm on a macros thing let me show you
how to count macros
I'm about to get so [__] ripped I'm
gonna get built yeah
thank you baby food
um I had the extra small one can I tell
you what my meal look uh my meal was
before this I went to Porto's three
cheese rolls two guava cheese rolls um
three and a half potato balls and a
carrot cake
yeah I love carrot cake I know no listen
you have to have these you have to do
this thank you it has to happen it's
Saturday you do whatever you want thank
you do whatever you want and I was gonna
beat myself up over it because clearly
that was a binge but then I was like you
know what no
I it's okay yeah I I you know I gave in
to a a big impulse and I enjoyed it
during like
but I'm sure I'll have a meltdown later
but you know what
um yeah move forward no don't have a
meltdown yeah
it's healthy to do that it's healthy to
do that it's healthy to it's unhealthy
to beat yourself up thank you poor this
is like a very famous like Cuban bakery
right in L.A it's like such an
institution I feel like every guy loves
it you know who is my best like when I
was in my spinny eating disorderly
thoughts who always helped me out was
Lauren Greenberg oh she would she would
be like she said this thing to me that
was like so life-changing what she said
I binge ate once and I was like oh I
feel so bad and she was like
it would take you two days tops to not
to flush that out of it she's like
there's just no way you could in one
binge like ruin your life or whatever
yeah it's mostly just a psychological
thing it really helps me break that sort
of like I ruined I ruined everything or
whatever and now I can do whatever it's
like
but I'm fine it's fun being on a plan I
feel good I've had a lot of people reach
out to me about like how to overcome
binge eating disorder and I I don't have
like I feel like we need to come up with
like a specific
like nothing is specifically you're
right that's the thing I think with
eating disorders it's like you're
looking to other people's bodies the way
they look you're trying to get something
that's like outside of yourself you
really have to just like be mindful and
be like am I hungry right now well am I
like intuitive eating is a big headline
I would say and then also when I think
back on what helped me and when I went
to that 30-day treatment program it was
a lot of therapy it wasn't like it was
all just about food and nutrition like
it was a lot of therapy yeah because
it's something else right it's like a
right offset of something because
obviously I was eating I I do think it's
just it also is like the habit of that's
what you go to for Comfort it's
basically what binge eating is right I
mean for me
um because I had such a like a
controlling mother who always controlled
what I ate I didn't know how to eat for
myself when I got older so it was very
like you know I purged a lot what the
[__] is going on it's just like what
your birthday is gonna be at the end of
this week
how is it again again
wait we're all confused it's on the same
day every year wait this is your third
trash Tuesday birthday
so Return of the cupcake yeah
when we had the cupcake last there's no
way it's been a year it there's no way
what was it
it was your birthday
the wheelchair of the first year in the
wheelchair the first year which we had
to move her out cinnamon pecan uh crumb
cupcakes and vanilla bean from Air1
thank you so much so much
well no I'll tell I had an eating
disorder I'll tell you I don't have I'll
tell you one thing I don't have an
eating disorder but I'm about to be
[__] ripped and I'm not gonna be
drawing my abs on any more [__] I
would love to see y'all enjoy one of the
cupcakes not me
[__]
not do it I would be the one I want food
for you today thank you not till Monday
I'll be the one that does it but have
you guys heard of this study where I
think it's called like the milkshake
study where basically they gave what
we're talking about anal again
they gave two control groups
um the same milkshake and one they said
like this is like a protein a diet
healthy milkshake Light low calorie and
the other one they're like this is a
full like sugar sweet milkshake and then
they studied their way their like
stomachs reacted to it and the people
who were told that there was more in
there like were more satiated yeah the
results are here on if you want to read
them during the second interval
um participants were asked to drink and
rate the milkshakes results the mindset
of indulgence produce a dramatically
steeper decline in ghrelin which is the
hunger hormone after consuming the shake
whereas the mindset of the scent the
mindset of sensibility produced a
relatively flat ghrelin response so
ghrelin is the hormone in your body that
makes you hungry leptin is the hormone
in your body that causes satiation like
it's time
I was gonna say I think Annie has
something mean to say to me
but so I think that then by that logic
when you eat you're supposed to are you
supposed to then assume it's more than
what it is so that you get more full or
I thought you were going to say
something completely different about the
results I thought you said
um people who thought that it was
healthy for them actually like didn't
gain weight and the people that thought
it was bad for them gained weight that's
what I thought I was gonna be and then
we were like this is awesome yeah that's
[__] awesome I can think my way out
of me I do believe I think like that I
kind of do too I do almost believe that
yeah wait which one is true that's not
mine is not true this is not true at all
I think it is though no you can't you
can't be tricked into saying oh you're
getting a diet burger or a fake burger
and then eat a burger and not gain
weight like okay so I've convinced
myself my whole life because one time I
think I must I must have had some like
weird thyroid thing happening when I was
19 years old but
um I ate a bunch of cookies during that
week really bad diet but then I ended up
losing so much weight it was probably
because of some thyroid issue but then
I've convinced myself since that um
simple carbs really shitty junky food
like candy just goes right and it
doesn't affect me so when I binge like
Porto's I don't believe I'll not
anything will happen to me and then
nothing happens to me you guys seriously
sometimes I get in a mindset where I'm
like it's so easy to lose weight I can
just like totally lose weight and I
change nothing and I lose weight I'm
telling you there is you guys are saying
that this is true no it will it can you
can Jedi mind trick yourself what it is
but
I think it's something else I think even
better than that is that you're not
giving a [__] and you're not obsessing
over food and I think when you don't
think and you don't count and you're not
tuned into the idea of food and you let
it go you're not you end up not eating
as much and also think your body's more
relaxed you know yeah you can just like
your [__] can just slide out you you're
not clinging I do agree with that that
the the less you always said not what I
said no well because you had to make it
about [__] sliding out okay I don't need
to think about [__]
you do need to think about [__] I agree
that the less you obsess and like count
and think about that does help but you
know well if you think about it like so
much of a woman's weight I just have
never been a man that's not that's the
only reason why I'm saying this but
hormones water retention like things
like sodium like little things will make
like before my period I'm 10 pounds
heavier than I am I will lose 10 pounds
I definitely wait okay not to go into
Esther's capitalism corner but here we
are
we are so [__] all of us the way we
grew up all the commercials for gushers
and Doritos those foods are poison made
to be addictive we didn't stand a chance
I can't wait till next week you're like
the face of gusher the Rebrand of
gushers I'm an investor I'm literally
looking for cream Savers like when
you're driving and McDonald's Burger
King Taco Bell it's like we didn't have
a chance these things were fed into our
brains and like it's impossible to get
them out and they taste so good they're
chemically designed to taste [__]
good but I think with the internet now
there's more you can see there's more
things more options I were evolving out
of that I think yes but I'm just saying
our starting place we were [__] and
it's not our fault that we struggle with
weight
[Music]
that was funny
so when I don't make fun of you it's
weirder yeah I don't like it no she's
like I'm like when I let you finish the
sentence you're like
right like sugar like right
um wait you sent me a really Grim
article
ouster sends me is never happy you send
me happy things she always sends me the
darkest most Grim pages and you know
what she sent me she sent me an article
in the New York Times basically where
this person who was in a body bag was
like fighting to claw out of the box
it was pronounced oh my God that was so
[__] up that's literally the scariest
thing I've ever seen in my life me too I
am just curious I'm literally laughing
at a funeral okay let me read a let me
read a headline a patient declared dead
is found in a body bag gasping first
this is because Esther [__] so lazy
she's afraid they're gonna zip her up
she's worried she's put herself into
this only Esther would relate to this
Storyline by the way let's see what else
you can relate to a 66 year old woman
was taken to a funeral home where
workers discovered her chest moving a
report said and an Alzheimer's Care
Center in Iowa that declared her dead
was fine ten thousand dollars I just
want to know a thousand I just wanna
know how does it happen how are you
and then wake up does that happen
I mean I I don't know they are blaming
it on the nurse they're saying she was
at the end of a 12-hour shift and she
informed the doctors to release her to a
funeral home this happened more in 2020
in Michigan in 2018 in South Africa so
it happens every couple years that's
what I'm wondering it's like how does
this happen and then didn't win that
football player when he got injured on
the field didn't they declare him when
he died in front of all of us when we
saw him dead yeah yeah they brought him
back they like yeah but he was declared
dead for a moment he was yeah he wasn't
breathing from what a season to decide
to watch football I was like are you
[__] kidding me what is declaring
debt is essentially meaningless at this
point if you can go back on it now you
have to be resuscitated you have to
change all your merch please resuscitate
that [__] apparently you need like a
form signed to not be resuscitated
well my dad for us old and terminal as
he was which I kind of found like a
little bit of a Testament to like life
even though you think oh if I'm unable
to walk anymore if I'm able to change my
own diapers I should just be let go of
my dad didn't like he he was
resuscitated I'd say in the last four
years of his life a good seven eight
times and he wanted to be and he wanted
to be and in his mind he was like any
day or any moment that I can just see my
kids and my wife like around me living
but it would still be good it's good
enough for him and so he just never let
go so they seem upset
no but what did he have so what does
that mean did he have a heart attack and
then he was resisted like is that yeah
one time one uh twice he went septic and
then he went into
um um cardiac arrest and is
resuscitating just CPR yeah you get if
it's it's a cold blue so the car the
crash courses do not recess she has no
clue what it means that's so funny oh I
know it means bring you back well yeah
my mom just went through CPR training so
she's been like trying to practice on me
and my dad and my dad keeps being like I
am not he's like really concerned well
careful you could crack a rib doing that
especially could your parents oh my god
oh you can't practice get my stuff for
me
but but um yeah so if it's in like a
hospital setting then they bring like
the crash car then you get the pad and
the paddles and they do everything to
resuscitate you but I found it really
kind of interesting that most people
like especially because he was like what
close to 80 at that point he was like no
keep me the [__] alive I know my my feet
are gangrenous and everything's going
out and then we're just like he won't
let go well you hear a lot of stories
too like my mom I know my mom went when
my grandfather was in
um hospice
they were like you should probably come
by or whatever you know and my mom came
by and she was like you know you can go
like we're okay you can go and he died
like right away like there is a lot of
like where you like talk to people and
you're like you can I think for my dad
it's like he knew that he was leaving us
in a really bad place like financially
and that we weren't like settled like
yeah it's 10 grand every time they're
gonna resuscitate you dad what the hell
yeah I mean I think part of him was like
I kind of wanted to see if they're doing
a little bit better I want to you know
maybe no pressure is like did she win
her meat
yeah
um but it is yeah it's like sad but also
kind of Life affirming that someone
wants to just like
stay around oh I'm very Pro that I think
I would not want a loved one to be a DNR
person like I would like let's we're
we're holding out till the day what
would you do if one of your loved ones
was wearing your shirt
have you guys seen the movie um the
diving bell into butterfly no why did
you just said oh my God I did it's I I
watched a long time ago but the the
premise is this um he was like a and
it's based on a true story where it's a
man who was like I think he was like an
editor for like Vogue or something
yeah a high fashion magazine and he
basically has a stroke that causes him
this thing called locked in syndrome so
he is unable to move his entire body
completely paralyzed but he is so every
everything is firing still all cylinders
are firing his brain so he's basically
unable to communicate everyone thinks
he's in a vegetative state even though
everything is working up there so what
he ends up doing which is [__]
incredible is a nurse was able to
basically figure out that he was trying
to communicate with a little movement he
had in one eye because one eye had gone
bad and dried out so they had to shut it
and he was able to write a book using
blinking his eye system with the type of
blinking in his eyes we are useless we
are [__] useless but don't you think
if like okay if your dreams came true
and you didn't have to do anything and I
was that guy but wouldn't you want to
find a way yeah yeah yeah I think you
would like
especially because everything was still
switched on in there like that was my
biggest nightmare oh totally of course
that is like such a terrible fear to not
to be stuck and have no access to use
and speak yeah that's horrifying I mean
thankfully there are things like eegs
where they can measure the brain
activity and they are probably being
like Oh yeah this he's like it's there
oh okay I don't know if that they had it
at that time but like it was yeah we're
useless
this guy wrote a book with a tiny little
blinky eye yeah
oh my god
um sorry I had to do a little Biz
um I am
so glad that I have done all the work
I've done on myself that I
choose to have a good day every day and
I look at things like obviously I don't
wish to be have
frozen bodies in them or whatever it's
kind of locked in it's not just
paralyzed yeah he is paralyzed it's
paralyzed frozen body syndrome but what
does she say I have frozen shoulder
that's that's fine please carry on I'm
sorry sir
Esther flinched yesterday like she
thought I was gonna beat her up I I know
when P I had this is I don't know why
but friends of mine have said like when
I go like this you actually Flinch and
yeah you're a little thing the wind for
my hand could have flown you across the
room Whitney has pointed that out she's
like I think that you have anxiety and
fear because you're small you can't
she's like you can't survive on your own
oh that's like why you have donut to
make you feel big and tall we we wait
Esther this is like my dog Remy he has
to be very vocal and a growlier than my
other dogs because he's like if I if I
don't like speak for myself I'm gonna
get smushed like people are gonna sit on
me accidentally step on me so he has to
be he has to make himself known in a
room or else he will get smoshed yeah
Chihuahuas evolved oh yeah she's like a
chihuahua me yeah thank you she loves
Taco Bell
you're like Mr bubs do you guys know Mr
bubs
oh Mr clubs is a legend I love Mr Bob
what is who's Mr how do we not know
those famous dogs he's a famous Angry
Chihuahua we know dogs this guy
[Laughter]
oh my God is that how you guys see me we
have trained
um that's what you looked like when I
went to hug you yesterday
peel our food she's like are you gonna
hit me I was like hey you what are you
talking about I might no give you a
little bit of squeeze a little too tight
and I might pop out a little bit you
could write a book with me squeezing you
wait is what am I reading here La
magazine says that arawan is a new
dating spot yeah it's like an article
that came out a couple weeks ago saying
that after covid that people are kind of
sick of apps and they're going to Air1
to meet each other I think that's great
it makes me sick I love it it's more
centered around the Gaze but I'm sure
straight people can also meet uh oh my
God have you guys ever met someone like
out in the wild at like a grocery store
or a coffee shop and it's like turned
into a I dated a guy named Cowboy Carl I
met him listening he was selling drills
like he worked for the drill company but
he was selling drills at Home Depot and
so he was doing like uh he had like a
table of drills and I was like hi
that's another thing there's a Home
Depot husband hunting thing on Tick Tock
he was so [__] hot he was all these
girls are going to Home Depot and
looking for husbands oh you feel like
the kinds of men that are at Home Depot
are already married or working there
this is gonna sound crazy but the guy I
would say I the most in love I've ever
been in my life
um was a guy I met at yoga
yeah yeah
interesting he had like a herniated disc
and so like he was like some big Gruff
he kind of like you know but he he had
he had just had like surgery to fix like
a herniated disc so all he could do was
yoga and he was like one of two men in
there and yoga guys are so hot it gives
them such but he wasn't yoga guy he was
just there to kind of rehab his body
that's kind of hotter yeah
and so yeah I remember being like Oh my
God like I'm so in love with this person
it's crazy I don't think I've ever met
someone like at a well you're only there
once a week so not a yoga
at an exercise thing I don't know what
it is I just never really like you've
met people in The Comedy Store and stuff
that's probably wait do you remember the
guy on the hike
I almost dated that guy but he was too
douchebags we remind a guy in a height
there was a guy on a hike his name was
like Matt Matheson it was like Yeah Dave
Davidson was like this is not your name
was he Joe Joseph Maddie Matheson no it
wasn't him no he was not it was a height
please of course I only remember the hot
girl it was like but he was we were
making fun of his dog we were pretending
to be his dog we heard his dog's name so
like his dog's name was like killer or
something and they're like come here
killer we were trying to get the dog to
like come to defer to us over him
without him noticing and then he came up
and then I used to see him on the hike
all the time and he'd be like oh he's
such a soldier you already went to
Barry's boot camp today I'm like yeah I
did and then he was like call me and
then I looked his real up and I was like
I can't do this you looked up his real
was rough I wish I could remember
everything we could watch his workouts
oh no he like played a cop and
everything he was really what very very
fit as people in this industry what are
your thoughts on people putting their
acting rails on their Instagram
do your thing but Carla would be good
you're doing big hand just no like if
you're a professional actor we'll just
see it like on TV
or online okay right like like I don't
know that's just my take it's kind of a
turn off I think Esther or what are you
trying to [__] the person
why would it be a turn on or turn off to
you because if it's not something like
like really well done then I wouldn't it
would turn me off
unless it's a real of them in like a Tom
Cruise movie are you asking us someone
we're attracted to no no just anybody
you know what I think is that I have not
seen a acting real used in so long yeah
that it's like I think the internet
slowly but surely like social media
changed that where I think it would feel
so weird to see now but I think like
maybe 10 years ago it made sense to have
a website with that but now it's like
you just kind of post your luckily the
algorithm has ended the real has put the
real to rest and what do you think I
still see them what to do yeah I mean I
follow people who put their like
scenes on there
and I feel like these are specific
people I've unfollowed
I think like what everyone chooses to
post and not post is so personal and so
hard to put yourself in someone else's
shoes that I try to have no judgments
about it and just lead by example I do I
post what I post That's My Style because
you know what I'm posting if I'm leading
by example is that what you're thinking
I'm the leader of Instagram stories
that's what her name is that's her cult
leader name leader of Instagram stories
but like this is
I'm very aware that the things I post
probably make people in my real life
want to mute me
um think I'm annoying think I'm obsessed
with selling tickets or think that I'm
cool think that I do fun stuff think
that I'm funny like there's such a range
of what people could think that I
personally have completely taken all
judgment out of it because I'm like I
post whatever I want I don't care so you
post whatever you want I don't care if
you're judging other people's posts that
means you're being so judgmental of your
own [__] you're being so cringy of your
own thing yeah and you're probably
always looking back at your grid yeah
like I know I've done this before when
I've been insecure over like a girl say
for instance I'm like oh who's he
talking to that like oh is he interested
in her and what I find myself doing is
after I've looked at her
um Instagram I go back to my grid and
I'm like to kind of the point of view
her point of view what she would think
looking at my stuff I haven't done that
but that sounds fun but you know it's
it's seeing your Instagram through
someone else's eyes but what you think
she's seen yeah and it becomes this
whole cycle of like shame and like being
so critical of yourself
guys some obviously was a choice
it's hard like yeah what is your advice
on building cell phones I just tell
yourself you're the best just look in
the mirror tell yourself that's always
worked on yourself if something happens
try to grow from it you know try to
learn something from it don't just like
I just don't you know I never I try to
not have if something's bothering me I'm
like there's something there I have to
like investigate try to work on it I try
to not blame outward because there's no
like growth in that I'll never be able
to control other people so it's like
what is it about me
that this is upsetting you know and then
but I just I mean I just used to do the
stupid [__] where I would just like look
in the mirror and be like I love myself
I love myself and now it just like
totally works you know I'd like to share
a life hack
um you know I had a really rough year
last year and I want to share a life
hack that really got me through like the
the darkest days of my life is like you
know when you're feeling safe for
instance like super anxious super amped
and what you've learned from other
people like oh why don't you listen to
something meditative to like bring you
back down to like Earth something that
contrasts what you're currently feeling
and I think that's a mistake if you're
feeling amped listen to something so
surprising right through it like it's
almost like meet yourself where you're
at so like what I do now is like if I'm
feeling so anxious and so hyped and I am
not like everything is just on level 10.
I'll listen to like a stormzy song like
the song audacity where it's a little
bit more as opposed to like listening to
[__] Ram Das on it because before
it's like listen to something like soft
and meditative so if I'm feeling
heartbroken I want to lean into that
yeah do the most heartbreaking songs
ever I do that too but I instead of
those islands I kissed a girl funny girl
I kissed Don't Rain on My Parade
but do you know what I mean right it's
like meeting yourself where you're at I
don't think you should try to like
um bring yourself down a notch it's
almost like fully acknowledge where
you're at and just like create an
environment where it's almost like
you're swimming in it so it's it's hard
to fake things right yeah so it's like
if you're like feeling this way and then
you're listening to this it's like too
much of a contrast exactly like and then
when it's not working you're like oh and
you get even more like stress out over
it I feel like with anxiety and all the
bad emotions and stuff or not well
they're obviously not bad they're
they're showing something but I just I'm
like they're not serving me anymore it's
like I really just want to like lean
into only Bliss and happiness and I'm
it's been working like where I'm just
like when I start to get nervous I'm
like I'm like what am I choosing to be
nervous what's the point like I can just
choose that this is going to be the best
thing another life hack I have when I
get into panic attacks is even though I
don't believe it in that moment because
I feel like oh my god I think I'm dying
is to repeat the phrase so what so what
so what so what what oh but I'm dying so
what but it almost kind of just takes
the edge off it like it just it does
this like deactivation in me where
you're telling you're tricking your
brain into thinking oh it's not as big
of a threat as you think so what say it
over and over and over again so the [__]
what so what who cares so what I like
that a lot and I I because it's similar
to one that I've been working on of like
I get so upset about my feelings I'll be
like I can't believe I'm I can't stop
thinking about this I can't believe and
I get so judgmental but if I could just
be like Oh I'm upset so what you're
upset it's gonna pass it always does
yeah it would help that's the same thing
with anxiety if you if you start to fear
the fear if you start to fear the the
incoming like emotions of anxiety that's
just going to kind of um Avalanche into
even bigger bigger fear and then a
full-blown panic attack yeah I even had
to do this in a while but I talked about
on here before I found it on this like
80 thing where it's like when you're
spinning if you actually imagine what
the spin the direction the spin's going
if you go like I keep thinking about
this thought if you're like oh my God
it's like a tumbling forward thought if
you then like slow it down you just like
imagine the spinning slowing and then
you can like reverse the shape of it
then you're not out of the thought
you're now like
I like that does that work because
you're very like visual in your mind
it's not even I don't even like
visualize visualize it's like a feeling
of the visual thing even when I do
Ayahuasca it's like sometimes I'm not
actually seeing things I'm like feeling
the thing I'm seeing
I like that I also try to think a lot
about like forward like what's ahead of
me you know that's because a lot of the
looping spirally stuff is all about
stuff in the past so it's like okay well
just like my eyes are looking forward so
I'll just go where they're looking yeah
or I mean not even forward sometimes
like future thinking can be super like
you know anxiety inducing just like
[__] look I'm alive you're right that
is better I'm right here like nothing's
happened that's it I will just be like
I'm so excited for all the amazing
things that are coming I'm so excited I
just got like excited about things
I like that because it's like what am I
gonna like go like oh no bad things are
like why would I think that that's crazy
I'm making up that everything's gonna be
bad so I just I'm like oh my God it's so
exciting that everything I've ever
wanted is gonna come true because if you
think about all the things that you have
wanted that have come true it's like why
wouldn't they keep happening right
but it really depends am I on my period
or am I not wait I always it's so crazy
how often it's so easy to forget that
like you're a woman the day of your
cycle where you're at affects everything
like it really has the power to make you
unable to exercise or to if you're on a
different day like you have so much
energy it just it [__] with us so much
it also [__] with whether or not I find
someone attractive really like yeah I
mean when I'm ovulating the like if you
meet if I meet a guy while I'm ovulating
the chances of me and him hitting it off
very high if I meet that same person at
a different time in my cycle
low I told I think I must have talked to
you guys about this but I used to always
have the thing where it was like
nighttime morning time at night it was
like I was this [__] werewolf I was
like everyone's hot I'm gonna tell them
all my true feelings and then the next
day I would be in the morning I'd be
like I don't even find this person
attractive I just told them I wanted to
go to prom with them or whatever oh my
God like I just decided to make it
official with this [__] ugly guy like
I gotta stop hanging out of high school
but I had this yeah Todd was cool with
it we got through it it was the same
thing as like making plans again when
I'm ovulating I'm like yeah I'll
absolutely go to your birthday party two
weeks from now and then two weeks from
now I'm on my period I'm like I do not
want to [__] go don't make it okay
two things in this though I now have the
courage to just be like I'm backing out
of these plans sorry I can't do this I
change my everything has changed one I'm
able to do that but also I'm so much
more careful about
what I agree to now like I used to be
just like people please like immediately
agree yes yes Todd's always like you say
yes to should I know you're gonna be so
pissed like my dad would I call it [__]
you Stan because my dad would his friend
would call him he'd be on the phone he'd
be like yeah of course Dan I'll get
right to it you know oh I'd love to such
an honor thank you and I could be like
[__] you Stan
but I'm just like I know my pattern so
now I'm just trying to like if you just
slow everything down like if someone
asks you to do something if you go like
either not get back to them right away
or like tell them you're thinking about
it either way is fine it's like
I think that we're so like used to like
everyone being like this yeah but
sometimes you just have to retrain
people where it's like you're our lives
are so busy it's like we're doing a
bunch of [__] it's like sometimes you
need a second to think about things and
to just like wait on it yeah
I think I do a really good job of
telling people up front they're like I
don't do much I'm I'm kind of a Hermit
and so it's like know that about me when
you like invite me to things but I have
a friend whom I love so dearly because
he really knows how to work with my
moods and it's Jean and be like has your
cycle in his phone but he does so well
that I so appreciate is that he'll give
me five different options to hang out
that week he'll be like do you want to
watch this at this time on Tuesday if
not no problem and he just takes the
pressure off or we could go get you
you're that fig yogurt you like at the
farmer's market on Sunday but he gives
me so many options for hangs that it's
just so no pressure this is like a
really nice event I know there's not
that many jeans in the world there
aren't and so it when I hang out with
him it's like I feel like I genuinely
want to be there yeah but also it's like
the people that are mad at you when you
can't hang out it's like yeah are you
mentally [__] ill we're too old for
this [__] like people that are so
attached like if you like why would you
care if I'm there or not yeah I'm sure
it could be fun or whatever but if
something else came up you want me to
abandon the thing that in my heart is
more important to come to the you know
what I mean do you know what I mean yeah
no totally I also just I'm not I can't
believe what a lovely man Jean is and
that like you and Dave have him in your
life it just sounds really nice
oh you know if he's not with me I'm like
what are you doing today oh I'm about to
see Dave it's always Dave no I know like
several nights a week it's like Dave
will come up to me after dinner he's
like so Jean just texted me I'm like
okay you can go yeah Gina's offering
something that you don't flexibility
isn't it cute that Dave and I share uh
sort of bestie yes I love it I like I
yeah are you gonna let him [__] you in
the ass a little extra now no dude oh my
god well apparently it's this has been
my birthday episode today
um happy birthday to me right
I'm so confused what day is it what year
is it what year I feel like we're
operating in like hyper speeds what's up
I I can't keep up with time anymore has
it really been a whole year I'm freaking
the [__] out young and cute yeah it's
like how could it be three years yes so
your birthday's March 2nd okay thank you
how can I still how can I still look
this stunning I know Esther birthdays
I'm just getting so much prettier no me
too I know I feel like I have a glow
it's like it is weird people keep asking
if I'm pregnant and I'm not insulted by
it I'm like I know right I know that I'm
an abortion Queen but I do know what
it's like to be pregnant for at the very
least like five to six weeks and let me
tell you I'm stunning in those five to
six weeks I don't feel great but my hair
is shiny I there's like an extra pep to
my step I'm hiking every day yeah cause
you're trying to get it out it's like my
over exercise
[Laughter]
oh my god well you guys thank you so
much for tuning in today we really we
need you we love you and we know that
you need us too and we thank you for
we're not needy she picked a weird word
we attract we don't attack no we do
attack
and so we're attacking you with love and
kisses and we hope you have a wonderful
bester's birthday whenever it is
see you next week with an all new
episode bye guys
[Music]
foreign